après un an de travail pour les
seizièmes volontaire et la classe du lys
du collège raymond vergès
les collégiens présentent leur projet de
réhabilitation et de revalorisation de
la partie verger de leurs arboretum
saveur est fière de vous présenter le
transit que nous avons menées au cours
de cette année scolaire il ya plusieurs
années des élèves et des professeurs ont
fait un abo atteint au sein de ce
collège il a dû refuser plus ou moins
laissé à l'abandon
notre objectif de réhabiliter et de
valoriser la partie vierge et de
l'arboretum un projet financé en grande
partie par leur participation au
concours du plus beau collège fleuries
organisé par le département depuis 2012
dès leur inscription au concours chaque
collège se voir remettre une somme de
3500 euros allouée à cette action les
élèves ont travaillé sur leur temps
libre afin de nettoyer cette partie du
collège laissé à l'abandon depuis
quelques années par la suite ils se sont
documentés sur chacune des espèces
exotiques présente dans ce verger
nous avons entrepris de classer
commencez déjà par placer des panneaux
informatifs devant chacun des arbres
présents dans cet arboretum sur lesquels
on a mis un système de flashcode afin
que ces panneaux soit chacun de ces
panneaux soient mis en relation avec des
fichiers numériques qui se trouve sur le
site du collège des travaux d'élagage on
a mis en place les pas japonais voilà
quand je voulais dit on a nettoyé et
tout ça ça a été encadrée aussi par les
agents de service qui nous ont vraiment
énormément aidé tout au long du projet
des agents mise à disposition par le
département afin de soutenir les élèves
dans la mise en place et la réalisation
de cet espace ils ont ainsi partagé
leurs connaissances et permis aux
collégiens de découvrir une diversité de
métiers
cette action a aussi permis aux élèves
de s'approprier le patrimoine local
réunionnais très riche en biodiversité
mais pour moi c'est fondamental
fondamentale tout simplement là pour la
bonne et simple raison que je suis un
ancien professeur de sciences svt celle
que j'ai connue dans mon camp j'étais
enseignant dans mon collège je
descendais vous voir les herbes même
séché avec mes élèves et la mettre un
outil comme celui là à la disposition de
nos élèves c'est extraordinaire en plus
de profiter de cet espace propice à leur
épanouissement
les élèves ont appris à travailler en
groupe à devenir acteur de la vie verte
en participant à l'embellissement de
leur cadre de vie et à respecter
l'environnement
cette action marque aussi le début d'un
partenariat avec l'équipe du jardin
botanique de la réunion mascarin qui a
guidé les élèves lors de la
revalorisation de l'arboretum voilà
objectif atteint pour cette première
année partenariat il y aura deux autres
années où on participera notamment à la
création d'un jardin créole dans une
partie qui restent vacantes ici sur le
collège et une troisième année où on
devrait éventuellement installer un
module alors ça peut être un rucher ça
peut être une serre à papillons on verra
ça en fonction du projet d'établissement
à ça ce projet les élèves du collège
raymond vergès dispose désormais d'un
espace vert embellie sur lequel nous
pourrons travailler les années suivantes